빌사 아미 간다 오늘은 대한민국
4교육 1번지 대치동에 왔습니다
[음악]
원래 대한민국 학원가는
1970년도지만 하더라도 거기
4대문안에 다 몰려 있었습니다 근데
도심 재배치를 통해서 이제 거기 너무
몰려 있으니까 나중에 이제 전쟁 났을
때 좀 위험하잖아요 그래서 그때
당시에 도심 재배치를 했어요 그래서
거기 있던 학원이라는 그리고 특히
거기 있는 명문 학교들을 다 강남으로
이전을 했습니다 그래서 그때 딱
이전한게 경기고등학교 그다음 시문
고등학교 이런 명문고등학교 학교들이
이쪽으로 이전하면서 이쪽에 학원가가
생기기 시작합니다 대치동에 그러면서
되게 좀 활발해지기 시작했고 그리고
한 1900년도 한 주후반 정도에
이제 사교육 열풍이 좀 불기
시작합니다 그래서 그러면서 학원들이
정말 우후죽순으로 생겨나기 시작했고
그때부터 어 대치동 학원가가 정말
대한민국 사교육 1번지라고 불릴
정도로 되게 진짜 전국에서 학원이
제일 많은 어 그런 동네가 됐다라고
좀 보시면 될 거 같습니다 그
대치동은 주변에 배우 상이 되게
많아요 그서 예를 들어서 음마
아파트라 뭐 레미안 대치 라든지 거기
개나리 아파트라 그래서 인근에 그런
배우 세대가 거의 몇만 세대가
있습니다 그래서 배우 세대도 되게
탄탄하고 학원가도 상권이 되게 좋고
그래서 거기 배우 세대에 있는
아파트들도 이런 명문 고등학교나 이런
대치동 학원가 때문에 가격이 계속
오르고 있습니다네 그래서 좀 이쪽
대치동은 강남구 내에서도 좀 약간
특수한 곳이라고 좀 보시면 될 거
같고 그리고 임대료 수준도 봤을 때
거의 탑 3이 안에 듭니다 어 강남구
전체 평당 임대료로 봤을 때이
대치동의 임대료가 상당히 좀 높은
수준이고 그 저희가 여기 실제로
임대도 해 보면 상부층 학원이 되게
임대가 잘 됩니다네 임대를 수준도
높고 그래서 아직까지는 되게 좀
대치동 상권이라는 뭐 투자 가치라는
뭐 이런 부분에 있어선 되게 좋은 거
같고 제가 서울시 상권 분석 데이터를
좀 봤는데 대치동 학원 가긴 하지만
실질적으로 돈을 가장 많이 쓰는 거는
40대 여성분이 제일 많이 씁니다
그리고 시간대는 시부터 9시 까지가
매출이 제일 높다 그러더라고요 그리고
이제 유동 인구는 10대 남성이 제일
많았고 이분들이 새벽에 좀 많이
움직이는 거 같더라고요 그래서 원래
이제 학원이 보통 10시에 끝나는데
그 이후에 좀 유동인 거 맞는 거
같습니다 데이터를 보니까 그 부분
한번 보면 좋을 거 같고 이렇게 좀
학생들도 있지만 학생들을 픽업하려고
오는 그런 부모님들이 잖아 그 어머님
분들이 거기서 식사도 하고 차도
마시고 뭐 쇼핑도 하고 해 가지고
상권이 좀 이렇게 활발하게 형성이 돼
있는 거 같습니다 그리고 거주 인구는
보통 3 40대 직장인 분들이 좀
많이 거주하고 있었고 그 소득 수준을
보니까 월 평균 한 700만 원
이상이더라도 허울 시가 평균 한
300만 원 정도인데 거의 두 배
이상 되게 소득 수준이 높은 분들이
좀 많이 거주하고 계시고 그리고
강남구 기준으로 평당 임대료가
대치동은 한 28만 원 정도
되더라고요 그래서 강남구 평균은 한
12만 원 거의 두 배 이상 되게
높았습니다 그래서 그만큼 대치동이
임대료 소준이 높고 소득 수준이 되게
높은 분들이 많이 살고 있는 곳이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다 그 제가
매각사례 좀 설명드릴 건데 21년도
66평 정도 되는 진짜 되게 낡은
주택이 하나 있었거든요 한 46억
정도에 매입을 했습니다 그래서 그거를
이제 멸실한 다음에 지하 2층 지상
6층 규모로 신축을 했고 연면적은
무려 한 200 정도로 되게 좀
높게지었습니다 그래서이 건물은
22년도 9월 달에 준공을 했는데
바로 다음 달에 학원이 통임대
들어왔어요 그래서 월세가 무려 3천만
원에 들어왔습니다 그래서 그거
들어오자마자
23년도 119억 매매을 했습니다 그
매입한 비온 46억 그다음 뭐
세금까지 하면 대략 뭐 50억 그리고
신축 비용이 이제 연면적 200평
있데 뭐 대략적으로 한 20억이라고
치면은 총 들어간게 한 70억 정도
됩니다 그리고 이제 매각한게 119억
이니까 차익이 거의 한 40억 후반
법인세 21% 빼면은 40억 내외에
이제 차익이 좀 발생되는 것으로 좀
예상이 되고요네 이분이 대출을 좀
많이 이용했습니다 그래서 매입할 때
약 한 40억 정도 대출을 받았고
그리고 신축할 때 한 16억 정도
대출을 받았습니다 토탈 한 56억
정도 대출을 받았어요 그래서 실제
투자된 현금은 제가 봤을 때 한 뭐
10억 중반에서 뭐 20억 내외일 것
같습니다 그 정도로 투자해 2년 만에
세금 다 빼고 한 40억 정도 번
사례라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 대치동 건물 투자 팁을 좀
말씀드리자면 대치동도 좀 나눠져
있어요 그까 이제 선능이면 상권
그다음에 삼성역이면 상권 같은
경우에는 오피스 상권입니다 그래서 좀
먹자 상권이 좀 많이 형성되 있고
그리고 이제 흔히 말하는 이제 대치동
학원가는 한티어 인근 음마 아파트
4사거리 배치 4거리 인근에 좀
학원이 많이 밀집 되어 있거든요 그
여러분들이 대치동이 좀이 블록마다 좀
나눠져 있는 거를 좀 알고 계시면
좋을 것 같고 그리고 이게 그 길마다
좀 상권이 달라요 학원이 많이 들어온
위치가 배로 바로 근처가 좀 학원이
많이 들어 있는데요 안쪽으로 갈수록
어 학원이 없고 다이 좀 주택가로
밀집이 많이 되어 있습니다 바로 진짜
도로에 따라서도 학원이나 빌딩 가치가
다르기 때문에 여러분들 만약에 대치도
항공가 초대하신다 그러면 길을 직접가
보셨으면 좋겠습니다 직접 가서 어디
길이 좀 확장이 잘되고 어떤 길에
어떤 학원이 들어와 있는지 직접
가서이 길의 장단점을 분석하는게 좋을
거 같은 진짜 바로 협에 길도 진짜
차이가 진짜 너무 많이납니다 그래서
나중에 이제 임대할 때도 그렇게
안쪽에 주택과 건물들의 임대가 또 잘
안 될 수도 있어요 그런 부분을 좀
기억하신 다음에 투자를 하시면 좋을
것 같습니다네 그래서 대치동 그 미래
좀 전망을 하자면 저는 대치동에서
제일 좋은 데는 삼성역 인근이라고
봅니다 그래서 거기 밑에는 행정
구역상 이제 대치동 있데 삼성역의
개발 호재가 일단 워낙 많기 때문에
투자 가치로는 저는 거기가 좀 제일
좋을 거 같아요 gbc 들어오면 그런
관련된 업체들이 거기에 인근에 또
많이 들어올 것 같습니다 대치동에서
거기가 좀 제일 좋다라고 생각하고 두
번째로는 일단 학원과 인근 여기는 뭐
건물을 짓거나 아니면 리모델링 하면
지금 임대 수요도 많고 임대료 수준도
되게 높습니다 건물 임대료가 되게
생각보다 너무 잘 나와요 요즘에 그
오피스 공실률이 되게 심하거든요
강남의 프라임급 건물들은 공실률이
낮아요 거기는 임대 수요가 많은데
이런 들어와서 있는 그런 강남 꼬마
빌딩 같은 경우에는 요즘에 공실률이
되게 높아졌습니다 언론에서 막 기사
보면 뭐 공실률 뭐 2% 뭐 1% 막
이렇게 공개를 하는데 그게 사실 그
데이터 기준을 보면은 프라임급
빌딩들이 한 2% 뭐이 정도거든요
거기는 공실률이 많이 없어요 근데
이런 강남 공화 빌딩 같은 경우에
요즘 공실률이 되게 높아져서 어찌됐든
대치동 같은 경우에는 위층까지 다
학원 수요가 있게 있기 때문에 그거를
받쳐 줄 만한 수요가 충분히 있는 곳
같습니다 대치동은 전 개인적으로 되게
좀 아직까지는 되게 좋게 보고 있고
근데 단점이라고 하면 어찌 됐든
사교육은 계속 좀 어떻게 좀 변할 거
같아요 그런 부분 때문에 좀 여러분
단기적으로 좋긴 하지만 좀 장기적으로
한 번 살펴볼 필요가 있다 뭐 저는
개인적으로 좀 렇게 생각을 합니다
그래서 대치동 상권에 대해서 좀
분석을 해봤는데이 영상이 마음에
드셨다면 구독과 좋아요 알림 설정까지
부탁드리겠습니다 l g s
[음악]